las noticias de salud o con mares Romero
salamaro Un saludo para usted Buenos
días Ángela y fue muy extrañada la
semana pasada gracias gracias a usted
por volver vamos a empezar hablando de
deporte y de los efectos que tiene sobre
el cerebro un nuevo estudio pone en duda
lo que se sabía hasta ahora nos cambia
el paradigma un poco Aunque siempre
tenemos que tratar todas estas cosas con
mucha precaución no en este caso es un
metaanálisis es decir que junto los
resultados de 24 análisis estudios
anteriores es muy útil eso para ver pues
qué líneas en común hay o qué disensos
hay en la ciencia alrededor de un tema
en este caso la conclusión principal del
estudio Es que la actividad física No
necesariamente mejora cómo funciona
nuestro cerebro No necesariamente
mejorar nuestra actividad cognitiva y
eso es curioso porque de los 22 de los
24 estudios que estaba analizando habían
concluido precisamente que sí había
beneficios sin embargo pues estos equipo
de investigación de la Universidad de
granada al juntarlos todo lo que
concluyen es que estadísticamente la
diferencia es muy baja no es tan
significativa como para hacer una
afirmación de que realmente hay un
resultado beneficioso y señalan por
ejemplo que uno de los motivos de que
los datos no sean suficientemente
concluyentes es que no se analiza por
distintos tipos de ejercicio hay un
Rango de edad muy amplio en todas las
muestras que se usan Entonces eso podría
influir en que no tengan o no hayan
querido llegar a una conclusión
definitiva alrededor de este vínculo no
importante hacer un momento para
explicar qué es lo que entendemos por
funciones cognitivas hoy vamos a hablar
mucho del cerebro y de esto Entonces
desde ya lo vamos a aclarar básicamente
es todo lo que implica recibir una
información externa que el cerebro la
procese y también poder responder de
formas tanto a nivel conscientes como
inconscientes estamos hablando de
procesos como la toma de decisiones como
la memoria el aprendizaje el lenguaje
las relaciones sociales pero por ejemplo
también incluso la orientación no
entonces todo esto es lo que entendemos
como procesos cognitivos y todo esto es
de lo que vamos a estar hablando en
Bueno hasta ahora con qué evidencia
contábamos sobre los beneficios del
deporte en el cerebro porque hay que
decir esto es una gran motivación para
mucha gente no totalmente no y no es que
no esté sustentada sobre muchos estudios
porque la mayoría indicaban que si hay
impacto y que sí es positivo no por
ejemplo hay un estudio de la revista
preventiva lo citaban los mismos centros
de control y prevención de enfermedades
de Estados Unidos que muestra que Cuanto
más inactivas están las personas más
prevalencias de deterioro cognitivo hay
no entre las personas activas
físicamente La prevalencia era de un
8,8% en mayores de 45 años por cierto y
entre los que eran inactivos esto llega
hasta el 15% una diferencia bastante
significativa en general se argumenta
que hay beneficios tanto directos es
decir hacer deporte aumenta por ejemplo
el flujo sanguíneo y el riego sanguíneo
en el cerebro y eso puede tener
beneficios sobre las neuronas y
básicamente sobre todo el órgano pero
también indirectos no al hacer ejercicio
se puede dormir Mejor Y eso Por ejemplo
tiene impactos en procesos como la
memoria sin ir más lejos sin embargo
como decíamos toca tener precaución con
estos resultados la ciencia es el
resultado de la suma de mucha
información que se va acumulando y con
el deporte o la actividad física pasa
como con la nutrición que lo hemos
hablado también otras veces no es
difícil separar todas las variables que
también pueden impactar por ejemplo
quién tiene tiempo para hacer deporte
Quién tiene los recursos también para
para tener la información de cómo se
hace deporte bien no es decir hay muchas
cosas ahí que influyen que pueden tener
que ver a las personas que hacen deporte
pueden tener una mejor alimentación
también entonces Bueno hay muchas
variables y que es difícil separarla y
por eso siempre Todas las conclusiones
las pondremos entre muchas comillas
vamos a seguir hablando del cerebro
ahora para profundizar en la relación
que existe usted lo decía entre la
presión sanguínea y un buen
funcionamiento Pues de nuestro cuerpo si
Este es otro estudio que se publicó
recientemente de la Universidad de
edimburgo se había observado ya de forma
bastante genérica que la presión
sanguínea alta es decir la hipertensión
podía tener un impacto en el desarrollo
de demencias o de nuevo de deterioros
cognitivos Sin embargo eran estudios que
mostraban un vínculo una relación sin
estar seguros de que esa relación fuera
causal es decir que la presión sanguínea
provocara o tuviera un impacto en el
desarrollo de estas demencias sin
embargo este tipo de investigación lo
que hizo fue combinar imágenes
cerebrales escáneres no marcadores
genéticos también Y estos estudios
observacionales para mostrar
definitivamente que sí existe una
relación causal entre estos dos factores
además es un estudio muy sólido porque
agrega muchísimos datos miles de datos
desde muchísimos pacientes y además
también encontraron por ejemplo las
regiones del cerebro que se ven
afectadas es decir han podido ir muy a
lo concreto Aquí hay una cita del autor
del estudio principal que dice eso no
que al combinar todas estas
aproximaciones estos abordajes a esta
problemática han conseguido entender
mejor los mecanismos y además digamos
que a futuro no podría también tener
muchos impactos en Cómo se tratan estas
estas dolencias entonces bueno Esto es
las principales conclusiones del estudio
que tenemos hasta ahora finalmente
Cuáles son esas regiones del cerebro que
se ven afectadas Pues los autores
hablaban de nuevo pero vamos a repasar
las principales por ejemplo hay una
región del cerebro que se llama putamen
que tiene mucho que ver con el
movimiento y el aprendizaje también con
los movimientos o los hábitos
automáticos está situada justo en el
centro del cerebro pero como veíamos
también en la cita anterior los autores
mencionan toda la materia Blanca del
cerebro que básicamente es lo que se
encuentra en las zonas profundas del
cerebro la corteza es la materia gris
dentro está la materia Blanca son como
las extensiones de las neuronas que
conectan diferentes regiones del cerebro
por ejemplo la corona radiata anterior
que es una de las que mencionan es una
especie de radio de fibras que se
encuentra en el interior del cerebro y
que conecta la corteza cerebral lo que
está en el exterior con la médula
espinal Lo mismo sucede con las otras
regiones como la radiación talámica
anterior entre otros que tienen mucho
que ver no con estas conexiones que
decíamos entre zonas distintas del
cerebro es muy importante además para
terminar entender Cuáles pueden ser
estos mecanismos Cuáles son las regiones
específicamente afectadas Porque el 30%
de la población vive con hipertensión
Así que tener una información concreta
puede ayudar al futuro también A saber
cómo prevenir este deterioro cognitivo o
estas demencias bueno muchos datos nos
trajo hoy Gracias a usted mal Muchas
gracias